a special guest a Yasser Lieutenant
Colonel Gerold lay shocked who's with
the Metro Police Department to talk
about one of the coolest programs at the
st. Louis chess club is doing the chess
a cop's program exactly and this
Lieutenant Colonel he's always busy we
see him
getting buzzed hopefully there's nothing
dangerous going thank you all right well
thank you so much for being with us
and before we get to the chess cops
program we know that you are an average
chess player yourself talk to us about
having something like chest B in your
great city and in your great program
well first off this program with the
police linking up with school children
and youngsters is so exciting and for me
because I love this sport as it is but
to see the looks on their faces and I
think you and I both realize everybody
in this room how important it is that
young people would even take up the
sport of chess it's such a it's a noble
endeavor and there's so much to learn
from it and with all the stress here in
the city for people living in the city
it's a great way for kids to get their
minds off of some of the things
troubling them and go at it and make the
point as we see here these wonderful
images of young people being able to
interface with the police officers in a
nice friendly competitive way I was
wonderful and since then I've been to
car lanes School on the Near North Side
just a little bit north of the atma the
downtown area and eight eight students
were in there I got to play with the
seventh grader but the such as through
such a good feeling in the room you know
and I asked mr. Jones yesterday I go how
after I left how was it received he goes
they thought it was neat that there was
a policeman taking out his time and they
could talk with and there's look there's
all of this is all benefits tell me how
the police themselves have taken to this
program and being able to to go in and
play chess against announcers so I'm a
st. Louis metropolitan police officer
the county had a jump start on us they
had probably 40 policemen there and they
loved it
so we just started our recruiting about
a month ago I have a lot of people that
want to do it and we went to one of the
training sessions Sunday so we're off to
a good start and what do you see is the
future of this program oh and yeah yeah
and and of course a lot of it has to do
how many more schools we can actually
get chess teams on and chess programs
the more that they can furbish will take
care of it from there and get policemen
there you must be just incredibly
exciting I remember I hosted the event
that day and the good feeling in the
room of course I was trash-talking as
many people I tell you what I went to
the public high school forum two weeks
ago st. Louis University I played the
young man who was dishing it out pretty
good a little more seriously more quiet
but it was great it was just great oh
that's and it's good if they're that
comfortable that they they want to do
that with a policeman I love that yes I
think that's something let's make that
point a bit more the fact is there has
been challenges in the community here in
st. Louis casinos has gotten a lot of
bad press around this topic of police
interfacing poorly with the community to
take a step like this it seems like you
should do with more things not just
chess but a lot of other activities
although chess of course is an
intellectual sport you get to sit down
and chat with your opponent as well
that's right there's a casual plus by
the way you walk in the first thing is
you sit down shake hands it's the next
thing after it's over shake hands there
is there's a lot of discussion although
the students are serious I will say this
I'll play a plug for the city we have a
really active Police Athletic
Association and our Police Athletic
League we have about 700 young people
involved from sports from basketball and
softball to boxing and we have a
tremendous track team and you get to see
policemen in a different light there I
work with the boxing program at 12th and
part one of our graduates of 2012 fought
for World Championship so there's a lot
of
there's a lot of really good feelings
there as a lot of police would just come
to watch the kids spar and just be there
they have questions it was incredible in
Ferguson I was there a lot we had to
send some members from our department
there and I was there
you can't lie the police were like how
do you know so many people I go they
came through the Police Athletic League
you know and I had friends out there you
know so it's important that's a
beautiful thing lieutenant colonel
Jarrell a shock taking time out of his
very busy day to be with the guys we
know you're committed service to the
community and expanding it through chess
is something wonderful thank you so much
keep up the great work thank you so much
thank you